el panorama fue centros de recolección
de firmas prácticamente vacíos en los
que había mayor presencia de guardia
nacional bolivariana testigos del perú
milicianos pero no de ciudadanos una
jornada en la que reinó la
desinformación incluso personas se
acercaban a estas mesas para preguntar
si se trataba de un operativo de
cedulación o de qué se trataba
recordemos que el consejo nacional
electoral anunció que se recogerían
estas firmas apenas hace cinco días no
les daba tiempo ni siquiera a los
solicitantes de hacer una campaña y de
informar a los ciudadanos cómo sería el
proceso uno de los movimientos que
solicitó el revocatorio contra maduro
ante el consejo nacional electoral
incluso llamó a no participar el día de
hoy en el proceso por considerar que era
inviable un término que también utilizó
dos de los rectores del consejo nacional
electoral que salvaron su voto por
considerar que el cronograma no era
viable para poder lograr recolectar 4.3
millones de firmas lo necesario para
activar este revocatorio contra nicolás
maduro también hubo obstrucción para el
trabajo de la prensa así lo denunció el
colegio nacional
en los próximos días
del movimiento por el revocatorio quien
llamó a no participar el día de hoy
anunció que acudiría el tribunal suprema
de justicia para solicitar la nulidad de
este proceso por considerarlo
inconstitucional